>> Tucker: BRETT KAVANAUGH AND
HIS WIFE ASHLEY APPEARED ON
"THE STORY" WITH
MARTHA MacCALLUM AN HOUR AGO
AND HE DENIED ALL ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT RALLIED
AGAINST HIM.
>> Judge Kavanaugh: I'VE NEVER
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ANYONE, NOT
IN HIGH SCHOOL, NOT EVER.
I'VE TREATED EVERYONE WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
LISTEN TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE KNOWN
THE BEST FOR MY WHOLE LIFE, THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE KNOWN ME SINCE
HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY SIGNED A LETTER FROM
HIGH SCHOOL SAYING I ALWAYS
TREATED THEM WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
>> Tucker: KAVANAUGH'S WIFE
CAME TO HIS DEFENSE AS WELL.
>> I KNOW BRETT, I'VE KNOWN HIM
FOR 17 YEARS AND THIS IS NOT AT
ALL -- IT'S REALLY HARD TO
BELIEVE.
HE'S DECENT AND KIND AND GOOD, I
AND I KNOW HIS HEART.
THIS IS NOT CONSISTENT WITH
BREAD.
BRETT.
>> THEY LOOK IN PAIN, BOTH OF
THEM.
>> Martha: WATCHING IT AGAIN,
THIS IS REALLY HARD FOR THEM AND
I FELT LIKE THEY WERE BOTH KIND
OF JUST TAMPING DOWN THE TEARS.
THEY WERE THIS CLOSE TO CRYING.
I THINK THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
INCREDIBLY EMOTIONALLY
DEVASTATING.
I THINK THEY THOUGHT AND WE ALL
THOUGHT THAT FIRST DAY AT THE
HEARING WHEN DEMOCRATS TRIED TO
SHUT DOWN THE WHOLE HEARING THAT
IT COULDN'T REALLY GET ANY WORSE
THAN THAT, THEN THEY THINK THEY
ARE ALL THE WAY THROUGH AND
SUDDENLY THOSE ACCUSATIONS START
COMING OUT OF THE WOODWORK.
I THINK IT WOULD WREAK HAVOC ON
ANYBODY.
THEY SEEM VERY SOLID TOGETHER
AND VERY UNITED IN THE EFFORT.
I SAID TO THEM, AT SOME POINT
DON'T YOU SAY, FORGET IT.
IT'S NOT WORTH IT ANYMORE, IT'S
TOO PAINFUL.
BUT THAT'S NOT AN OPTION.
>> Tucker: FOR A JOB THAT PAYS
LESS THAN THE AVERAGE LAWYER
SOMETIMES.
>> IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR
CHILDREN, WHICH WE HAVE HAD TO
HAVE.
ON BROADER TERMS, FOR OUR
YOUNGEST.
BUT THEY KNOW, IT'S BRETT AND
THAT THEY THE TRUTH.
AND WE TOLD THEM AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PROCESS, THIS
WILL BE NOT FUN SOMETIMES.
PEOPLE FEEL STRONGLY AND YOU
NEED TO KNOW THAT.
JUST REMEMBER, YOU KNOW YOUR DA
DAD.
>> Tucker: I BET THOSE GIRLS
WERE NOT PREPARED FOR THIS.
>> Martha: HOW COULD THEY BE?
YOU CAN IMAGINE AT THEIR AGE,
THEY ARE AT AGES TEN AND 12 IN
THAT AGE, I'M SURE IT'S
DEVASTATING FOR THEM.
I ASKED HIM SPECIFICALLY POINT
BLANK ABOUT ALL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THEM IN VERY SPECIFIC, GRAPHIC
TERMS.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO KIND OF FRAME THAT ISSUE, BUT
SHE ALSO SAID, THEY KNOW THEIR
DAD.
EVEN IN THE BEGINNING WHEN HE
GOT ROUGHED UP IN THAT FIRST
DAY, HE SAID HIS DAUGHTER CAME
DOWN AND GAVE THEM A HUG THAT
NIGHT.
AND THE ALLEGATIONS ARE WHAT
THEY ARE, HE'S GOING TO FACE
THAT ON THURSDAY.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THIS HAS
BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: WHEN CLARENCE
THOMAS WAS APPROVED AND OF
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR IN 1991,
HE MADE A DECISION THAT HE WAS
GOING TO FIGHT BACK IN A VERY
TOUGH WAY.
HE WAS NOT GOING TO GO DOWN.
DO YOU THINK KAVANAUGH HAS MADE
THAT DECISION?
>> Martha: KAVANAUGH WAS NOT
IN CLARENCE THOMAS FIGHTING
SHAPE TODAY.
AND WHEN HE BASICALLY LEVELED
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
IT'S SO POWERFUL.
THAT'S NOT THE FRAME OF MIND
THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH APPEARED TO
BE IN TODAY, ALTHOUGH HE MAY BE
THAT MOOD ON THURSDAY.
HE ASKED HIM SEVERAL TIMES, YOU
SAY THIS IS ALL FALSE, SO WHAT
DO YOU THINK IS BEHIND THIS?
WHERE DO YOU THINK THIS IS
COMING FROM?
IS THERE SOME KIND OF POLITICAL
VENDETTA AGAINST YOU THAT'S
BEING PLAYED OUT?
WE ALL KNOW THE CORNERS THAT
COULD BE COMING FROM BUT HE DID
NOT WANT TO GO THERE AT ALL.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO CONJECTURE
ABOUT ANY OF THAT.
AND CLARENCE THOMAS CLEARLY
CALLED IT WHAT HE THOUGHT IT
WAS.
A HIGH-TECH LYNCHING AND HE
THOUGHT THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE HAD SUNK TO SUCH LOWS
TO ENTERTAIN SOME OF THE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST HIM, THAT
THEY ENTERTAINED.
THAT WAS HIS FEELING, AND THEY
PERSEVERED.